what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we never finished like jeff lemire's
moon night run so we're gonna finish it
here uh so to kind of get you guys
caught up on what's happening and we'll
make this super short in effect mark
spector had just woken up in a mental
institution and that was it uh he didn't
really know how he got there he simply
just knew that he was there but over the
course of the first two volumes there
were a couple things that happened one
the egyptian goddess ammit had appeared
uh basically replacing somebody named dr
emmett and we'll talk about her here in
a minute but the other thing that had
gone on is mark had realized none of
what was happening was real that it was
all basically in his own mind more so
than that he came to the realization
that in order for him to basically heal
himself he couldn't keep ignoring the
personalities of jake lockley and steve
grant that he actually had to embrace
them and so what he ended up doing was
literally unifying those personalities
and then talking with those
personalities and letting them become a
part of him so it doesn't mean they're
gone it doesn't mean that like they've
somehow merged into a singular mark
specter who's now whole and doesn't have
any any split personalities they're
still there but basically they're kind
of a cohesive team right like a multiple
personality team if that makes any sense
but the thing about this and what's
really really cool here is in this final
part jeff lemire did a lot of changing
to the to the the mark specter mythos
and this comes by way of his youth that
when he was younger the way the story
opens up when he was younger he's just a
little kid who's playing in his
neighborhood you know chalk drawings all
that kind of stuff which is cool and
he's met by the arrival of another
younger kid and as the two of them start
talking mark introduces himself and
reveals that he lives in this apartment
building and the kid says i know and as
they start exchanging names the other
kid says my name is steven grant and so
what this means this is a huge
development here because what this means
is that the personality of steve grant
and jake lockley had always been a part
of mark spector's mind now the reason
why this is such a big deal is because
back in the day in marvel comics when it
came to the moon knight mythos initially
marvel pitched mark spector as a guy
with schizophrenia that he couldn't
distinguish between reality and fantasy
the old doug mink's stories focused
heavily on that so you didn't know if he
was actually the fist of an egyptian god
basically conscious weapon on earth
designed to take vengeance on people out
there or if he was a schizophrenic who
had made it all up over the years marvel
has of course changed that up to where
instead of mark spector having
schizophrenia he had disassociative
identity disorder basically he had
created the persona of jake lockley to
allow him to keep his ear to the ground
in order to know what kind of crime was
going on throughout parts of new york
that he simply didn't know about but he
also created the steve grant persona as
the billionaire personality that would
allow him to monitor white collar crime
and then fund his efforts as moon knight
what marvel did is they said that over
the course of his time as moon knight
having the jake lockley and the steve
grant personas mark spector got lost in
them to where he basically forgot that
he made them up and he started believing
that he was steve grant or started
believing he was jake lockley and didn't
know which one was actually him what
jeff lemire's doing here is basically
cleaning all that up and saying no no no
they weren't personalities that he
created there were personalities that
were already that were always there
right they had been there ever since he
was a little kid and this comes to a
head as he's having this conversation
with steve grant and showing him around
his room that when his dad walks in and
he's like mark who are you talking to
mark's like i'm just talking to my new
friend steven and that's when his dad
starts to realize okay there's something
seriously off here now what i want to do
is i want to kind of focus on this bit
of an origin for a second and then jump
back into the main thick of things
because jeff lemire jumps back and forth
back and forth and it can be really
difficult to keep up with or people who
don't really read comics and all and so
what this origin does is it basically
continues on with uh with mark's father
taking him to a psychologist or a
psychiatrist i think it's a psychiatrist
whichever one has like a medical degree
and can administer medication and things
like that but as they're having a
conversation while we don't necessarily
see that jake lockley persona manifest
when mark mark spector is a little kid
his father reveals that jake is one of
the personalities and he's actually
talked to jake before and so of course
the the doctor ends up asking mark to
leave the room while he talks to his
father and while mark's overhearing
things that's when he starts hearing
these things about like disassociative
identity disorder and like you know
therapy simply won't help there needs to
be like more aggressive treatment
medication being put in an institution
things like that but while that's
happening this is where khanshu begins
to target mark because as this is going
on pancho speaks to mark and says like
that guy is not your true father i'm
your true father and in time you will
come to me now the cool thing about this
is this is jeff lemire actually
borrowing from the x-men comics which is
a great concept so what chris claremont
did is he wrote a story in bizarre
adventures issue number 27 and what this
established is that when jean grey was a
little girl that her friend annie died
and that in that moment she let out a
kind of psychic backlash or psychic
feedback into the universe and that
xavier picked up on it which is how he
found jean in the first place but the
phoenix force detected it as well and
that over the course of jean grey's life
the phoenix watched her and in fact
there is a story called the
the what is it x-men the lost years or
something like that or like x-men like
the the lost adventures of the x-men
it's something along those lines i can't
remember it's been so long since i read
it but basically there's one point where
jean grey's traveling with the fantastic
four and she's temporarily possessed by
the phoenix and so basically it had been
watching her over the course of her life
so that when the phoenix saga kicked off
it was basically a long-awaited union
between gene and the phoenix force
that's what that's what jeff lemire's
borrowing from here that ever since uh
mark spector was a little kid he was
targeted by consu now the reason why
kanchu targeted him will become relevant
very very soon because what we end up
doing here is basically switching over
to a point where mark spector is
basically allowed to go to his father's
funeral now one of the people here is a
woman named dr emmett and this is the
reason why amit appeared as emmett in uh
in basically the mindscape of mark
spector because one it was a familiar
face a person he had already known so
most likely he would believe the
illusion he was seeing if he was
surrounded by people that he already
knew and with his mind being so broken
already mark spector would likely just
roll with it because it's just one of
the things that happens when you're him
and so as a result of that it's kind of
this brief little moment but that's why
ammit appears as emmett in uh in this
story but once mark of course gets to
the funeral he's basically talking to
his mom and he talks about how like he
believed his dad was happy to be rid of
him he believed his dad was just happy
to see him gone that he was always
embarrassed by the fact that mark had
disassociative identity disorder and in
fact there's one point whether or not
it's actually happening or he's joking
around um he's talking to his mom and
he's just like uh mark's not here
anymore right like uh like basically i'm
here now right uh basically jake lockley
is the one who took over this because
mark's too upset to handle what you know
to handle what comes next again it we're
not really sure that's what's actually
happening or or whatever the case is
when he goes to visit his bedroom
because of just the sheer amount of
weight and even anger and guilt that he
feels he ends up seeing the moon and he
hears the voice of konchi which beckons
him and so he ends up taking off and
then following that he enlists in the
marines but one of the things that goes
on and what jeff lemire says is that
over the course of this time in mark
spector's life konchu was always
reaching out to him he was always
talking to him he was always kind of
manipulating him and telling him like
you're just one step closer right you're
almost here soon we will be together
like that kind of a thing and there even
comes a point when he's in the marines
when he's kind of hypnotized by by
talking with konchu and ends up walking
out into a minefield and when he comes
to of course he's brought to a superior
who basically reveals that he knows mark
is has basically you know spent time in
a mental institution and the reality
here is that with mark having these
episodes where he seemingly blacks out
that he can't be in the marines because
of the fact that he lied to his
recruiters he's dishonorably discharged
and it makes sense to a degree right i
mean if these are the kind of episodes
he's having he could very well just like
walk into some kind of a roadside bomb
or end up just you know leading his team
or leading his group into some some kind
of hostile situation and get people
killed his mental faculties cannot be
trusted and while i've never been a
military man i do have to believe that
in the military you have to be able to
trust the mental faculties of the person
next to you if for no other reason to
ensure that you don't get each other
killed and so as a result of him
basically getting the boot he does the
only thing he can do which is turn to
what is in effect mercenary work now
initially it's just like an underground
fighting ring to a degree but that's
when he meets frenchie and between him
and frenchie they end up going into
what's basically bounty hunter mercenary
work where using their experiences they
start rounding people up one of the
first people they end up catching is
basically a guy called the wolf who's
basically a guy who runs drugs right who
creates heroin and so on and so forth
and they basically snatch him up and
they end up taking him away to the guy
that had a contract to get the wolf and
of course this man who put the contract
out turns out to be none other than raul
buschmann of course royal bushman
basically being the mercenary that works
with mark spector where they end up
meeting like the archaeologists and
marlene and then rob bushman betrays
them all he shoots mark specter leaves
him for dead and then mark spector
finally becomes a host of konchu what's
important about this and the reason why
this matters so much and why kanchu had
targeted mark ever since he was a little
kid is because the goal of konshu was to
basically destroy mark spector's mind
that his mind was already fractured it
was already broken so it was like it was
like a glass that was partially cracked
all you had to do was just flick it a
few times and the whole thing is going
to shatter and that's exactly what
kanchi wanted to do with mark spector
the reason being because once mark
spector's mind is completely and totally
broken he becomes an empty vessel and
what it does is it basically allows
conscious to take over the body of mark
specter because there is no mental
resistance right as long as mark
specter's consciousness is in there as
long as he's in control of his faculties
and his mind is aware he can fight off
the influence of conscie but if there is
nothing more than a broken mind that
would be in what you or i would call a
mental vegetative state then it just
it's literally like just leaving the
door open in a house all conscious has
to do is just walk in and then he would
basically be a god on earth right so
again you know realizing that that was
the case and realizing that's what's
going on what it does is it circles back
to everything happening in the mindscape
of mark spector basically his attempt to
fight against konshu because he realizes
that's what's going on here the khanshu
is basically manipulating him and kanchu
is trying to use his broken mind as a
means to enter into the real world and
so what this does is it basically leads
to to him kind of traveling back to
again this this kind of diner in this
mindscape which is led by by a woman
named gina again kind of a a mental
assistant of sorts it's one of those
mental aspects that keeps him anchored
to him not losing himself inside of his
own mind but as he travels back directly
to uh to what's essentially anubis that
anubis is in possession of crawley and
of course mark spector wants to get
crawly back and then ultimately face off
against konchu and destroy khanshu
thereby riding all the wrongs as he sees
it but with anubis in possession of uh
of crawley the response of anubis is no
like i'm not gonna give you i'm not
gonna give you crawly back he belongs to
me now i'm taking him to what is in
effect the underworld right the
afterlife that kind of a thing and so
mark spector basically tries to to
broker a deal between the two and
ultimately anubis does and newbie says
okay fine if what you want is crawley
you need to bring me something travel to
the overvoid find the thing that i want
and bring it back here you'll know it
when you see it and of course mark
spectre ends up traveling to the
overvoid now for those of you guys who
don't know the overvoid is the realm
specifically where the egyptian gods
reside in marvel comics you have all
different kinds of realms where
different people basically spend time
when it comes to the egyptian gods
because their mythos is so closely
intertwined uh they really just kind of
occupy in a singular place right that
the egyptian gods were all basically
created by amin ra also known as the
demiurge and that in turn almond raw
fathered all these different gods that
you see here so the old gods versus the
new gods is kind of what we're talking
about the the egyptian godly mythos is
starkly different from something like
the greek gods right they exist in
olympus where then you have the gods of
like odin and those guys who basically
hang out in asgard right and then you've
got like vishnu and you've got all those
places they they all have their own
individual rounds it doesn't mean they
can't meet and in fact amon raw is a
member of the council of godheads so
when like odin and zeus and vishnu and
aman ra and all these guys meet because
something huge is popping off like the
infinity gauntlet story uh from back in
the 90s they'll all meet in a central
location but they all go back to their
quote unquote godly realms right their
homes and so that's really what the
overvoid is now of course mark spector
getting in here is immediately attacked
[Laughter]
by different henchmen and whatnot and is
ultimately taken by these forces of uh
of the overvoid would seem to have taken
control but when he's put in this prison
that way that's when he's basically met
by and put who is essentially the love
interest of uh of anubis and that's when
he realizes this is what anubis wants so
my job here is to basically free and put
i think it's how you pronounce that and
then take her back to anubis right and
then that way i can get crawly and then
we can move on from there and so the
funny thing about this is that as as all
this goes down mark is immediately taken
by one of these of these henchmen
essentially and then brought for
sacrifice and he is actually gonna be
killed right like literally they intend
to kill him now technically again this
is all kind of happening inside of his
own mind but his spirit is basically in
this realm right this portion of his
mind is in this realm so imagine if for
example your consciousness could leave
your body and travel to an ethereal
realm what do you think would happen if
your consciousness was destroyed that
consciousness that personality wouldn't
be able to come back and so because of
the fact that what you have here is
basically mark spector who has
essentially become the ruler of his own
body that like the moon knight
personality and the steve grant
personality and the jake lockley
personalities no longer have control
over his own body this would be the
final step and so if he's killed here in
the overvoid then there is no one to
house the body of mark specter which
means honshu can take it over so while
konchu isn't necessarily the one
directing mark to the overvoid it really
is anubis at the end of the day konchu's
goal could still be achieved here and so
of course in the middle of all this you
end up having the other personalities of
mark spector that jump in and
effectively save the day and so again in
his own mind experiencing all this his
personality basically transitioning to
the overvoid the moon knight personality
travels to the overvoid as well along
with the steve grant personality doing
the exact same thing now of course steve
grant's there more to like free and put
than anything else because the guy can't
fight he can't fight at all he even says
that
good job steve grant you got input and
he's like yeah cool you know uh i
usually leave the fighting up to you
guys you know i'm i'm more of just i'm
the money right like i'm i'm the
financier
the benefactor you know that kind of a
thing but again like as they're
surrounded they're ultimately rescued by
what looks like jake lockley in a
spaceship so that's cool obviously when
things go on inside your own head things
tend to go off the rails
but with all these personalities
basically working together uh that in
turn essentially allows them to
transition back to the realm of anubis
and in bringing and put to anubis at
that point crawley is free now what this
does here is it basically leads to mark
essentially reconciling with jake
lockley and steve grant and the moon
knight persona now something else i want
to specify here in the comics moon
knight is his own personality but he's
not the guy that mark specter dresses up
as right he really is his own
personality so imagine that when bruce
wayne when he becomes batman he's like a
totally different personality he knows
the kind of stuff that bruce wayne does
but he's like a wholly different person
it's not just bruce wayne putting on a
mask and beating up criminals in the
middle of the night that's not really
what this is right so that's one of the
reasons one of the things i want to
specify here that i think is incredibly
important because i feel like people
seeing moon knight there is going to
throw them off yeah so moonite is his
own guy but following that of course
what they basically say is because of
the conversation that we had before you
are the prime personality mark spector
right like when you were born your
parents named you mark spector you are
the main personality here we're backups
right we're backup singers and and
because this is your story this is your
body we're here if you need us but this
is a fight that you have to fight on
your own against uh against khanshu
right you are the one that he sees
control of you're the one that he seeks
to destroy you have to be the one to
defeat him in order to fix yourself and
so basically with crawley being freed at
that point he goes down and or he goes
and starts tracking down consu now this
is a really really cool thing because
what happens in this conversation he
basically says like let this power come
through you mark like basically merge
with me right let like let my power
become your power now what he's secretly
trying to do here is he's trying to
trick mark he's trying to dupe him if
mark buys in to what it is that kanshi
was saying this is him basically letting
konchu take over his body that's
essentially what it would be uh that
ultimately he's like no that's not gonna
happen right like i came here to quite
literally kill you now he does what he
can but at the end of the day he's
fighting against a god inside of his own
mind and that ultimately this is mark
spector kind of at his most or not
really seeing himself as he should so to
give you guys perspective here what this
is and i know this is going to sound a
little crazy but bear with me here
because i know all of you guys have
experienced this have you guys
experienced that kind of thing like
maybe it's uh some measure of a lack of
self-confidence right or you're not as
sure of yourself as you should be and so
you have that voice in the back of your
head that constantly tells you like you
can't achieve that you can't do that
there's no way that's going to work you
are going to fail right that that voice
in the back of your head that doubts you
all the time that's your subconscious
speaking from its interpretation of your
life experiences doesn't mean that
interpretation's right but that's what
your subconscious is doing uh what this
is is it's basically your subconscious
trying to drag you down to what it knows
whereas you are trying to break free of
these chains your subconscious has
around you and trying to trick you into
believing that you're not worth the damn
this is what mark spector is
experiencing right now not necessarily
confidence but in the sense that he's
always been kind of a passenger in his
own life in a lot of ways that sure when
he was a mercenary he kind of did his
own thing but the reality here is that
he sees himself as broken so he believes
he's broken he believes that he can't
overcome the power of conscu because he
doesn't think he can and what's going on
here is him coming to terms with the
fact that in his own mind it's not
conscious that's god it's him he
controls everything there is nothing
inside of his world in his own mind that
happens without him allowing it and so
if konchu were to destroy him in his own
mind it's because he just sat down and
gave up whereas what should be happening
here a man of stature a man of
confidence konchu becomes a virtually
useless thing and that's exactly what
starts to happen here that as khanshu
intimidates him as he taunts him as he
kind of gives them a hard time conscious
says you are here the place where all
roads lead this place will be your tomb
mark so i have one question my son are
you ready and the response of mark
finally coming into his own and finally
recognizing that konchu inside of mark's
own mind is only as powerful as mark
allows him to be that he says that's not
the question konchu the question is are
you and as the two of them meet each
other conscious starts screwing with his
head right he literally starts using all
these past experiences all these
mistakes that mark believes he's made
over the course of his life and that
really is the weapon of your
subconscious right if your subconscious
were a were like your mortal enemy which
i would argue depending on your life
experiences it can be its weapon is
regret its weapon is fear and its weapon
is self-doubt every mistake you've made
over the course of your life everything
that you believe that you've done wrong
over the course of your life your
subconscious will use that as a weapon
it's a sword it's mace it's axe it's
what it uses to chop you down and so as
long as you can maintain that personal
armor your subconscious can't do
anything to you and that's exactly what
mark is going through right here that
he's starting to realize again conscious
only as powerful as he allows him to be
right he's only that capable and so one
of the things that you basically end up
finding out here is that what's actually
happening here in the real world is that
mark is being broken down to a degree by
ammon right that he's basically being
being literally held in place and so
what goes on here and what's what's
really really interesting is you get
this kind of explanation here right to
to a bit of a degree right this sort of
explanation from kanchu and this is
where people talk about the nature of
kanchu in relation to the moon night
mythos that when mark spector was left
for dead by raul buschmann and he was
placed before the statue of konchu that
kanchu had readily admitted i have
always watched you mark i have been
watching you for a long time he says
this is a flashback mark it is being
intercut with a presence and he says the
past and the present intermingle they
blend together and become one just like
different aspects of your broken mind i
will rid you of yourself i will hollow
you out and make you my perfect vessel
and he says this means little here the
moment of your birth is here and there
it is then and now all times lead to
this instant what's going on here is
that where conscious inside the
mindscape of mark spector is trying to
wear him down trying to convince him
that he that he cannot overcome konshu
the conscious just way more powerful
than he is the other part of it is that
amit working alongside konchu is trying
to basically prepare mark's body to be
become a host for uh for for conscious
himself right and so again what goes on
here is quite literally mark spector
breaks free from his confinement and
then just knocks out emmett
and then in doing that finally goes and
confronts konshu right again this is
where kanchu is messing with his mind
where he's kind of changing things
around as far as mark goes keep in mind
this whole story is happening in his
head there's nothing here in this story
that's really going on in the real world
and so once he comes face to face with
konshu and meets with him that he says
like we're not just going to beat you
kanchu we're going to break you and the
response of konshu is i mean you could
but like your mind's so already broken
like literally everything you know is my
weapon mark like everything that you
that you believe it's my tool to use you
believe that we're here in new york no
we're not we're on the moon and you
think i'm conscious no i'm jack russell
i'm werewolf by night and of course mark
fighting against these things is like no
none of this is real this is not real
there even comes a point where conscious
manifests raul bushman the mortal enemy
of mark spectre and even to a degree
he's somewhat fierce but like overcoming
raul bushman and then like like parker
robbins the hood and like jack russell
coming back and like all these different
villains this is mark realizing no none
of this is real this is you conscious
and it was always you these are just
illusions that you're creating in an
illusory mind right like yes my mind is
broken yes i have these personalities
but it doesn't mean that i can't have a
life conscious and it doesn't mean that
my personalities and i can't find some
way to mingle to co-exist over the
course of my life i've ignored them i
have blown them off i have treated them
like they're not there but one way or
another they are going to manifest but
if we can coexist in some measure of
harmony then in that at that point my
life is my own right i use them when i
need them right i bring out the
moonlight personality when i have to
beat somebody up in the middle of the
night i bring out the steve grant
personality when i need to know what's
going on in the world and when steve
grant has to present himself to whatever
environment he's in and i can bring out
the jake lockley persona when i need to
keep my my ear to the ground on crime
they are not i mean sure their
personalities they have thoughts
feelings things like that but they are a
part of me and if they are a part of me
they are just like my heart and my arms
and my legs they serve a purpose they
are something to be used to achieve a
particular goal he doesn't come across
that perspective in the sense that he's
like they are worthless they only serve
some limited purpose it's simply him
saying we are simply a cohesive unit and
he says i am sick right i know that i
will never be cured this is always going
to be who i am and he says but i can
still live i can still have a life and i
won't let you ruin that for me anymore
and that we're conscious bets right this
is literally mark spector overcoming
that part of himself right that kind of
self-doubt right that that lack of
confidence his subconscious right if
that's really what country represents
it's him overcoming that and saying no
kanchu i am mark spector i am stephen
grant i am jake lockley and we are going
to be okay we are going to live with who
we are we are moon knight and we never
needed you and in doing that totally
destroys konshu right like kills him and
so one of the things to know is this is
conscious impact on mark spector's mind
i mean kanchu is a literal egyptian god
so mark specter doesn't quite have the
power to destroy him even when mark
spector had the phoenix force in the
more recent avengers run all he could do
was defeat konchu and then kanchi was
locked away in an asgardian south so
that's really where he resides but at
the moment mark spector now has some
measure of inner peace and what this
does is it allows him to go forward
essentially as mr knight so for those of
you guys who are currently following our
videos on jed mckay's moon night run
which you'll also find in the in the
description of this video or card or
something like that the video itself
this segues directly into that i mean
there's a little a few things that
happen in between right in terms of like
his solo series it goes from this to jed
mckay so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think about this down in
the comments section and i will catch
you all later
peace
you